you
[Music]
okay so we're here now for the last
session of the day we have tumor
fantastic talks and then a great keynote
so I'm excited to introduce Luis from
Inter last who's going to talk about
visual data management systems
presentation essentially we shock and I
were working at into labs on this
project the visual data management
system for the last two years or so and
last November she decided to quit Intel
and or she startup based on PDMS so she
has that going on right now and we've
been working together the last couple of
months on a new release for vide MS
which is an open source project that's
why we keep on working together and the
idea was to present some of the new
things that we have going on on medium
as the new features that we added some
some of the roadmap up to this point we
kind of have the same things but sadly
at some point the paths will diverge and
I guess which I will start getting some
new features on the non open source
version of the project so just a little
bit of background for you to know why
this thing and maybe let me start by a
motivation why we started with this
project called video -2 visual data
management system and we started in the
context of the visual cloud systems
research at Inter labs we're thinking
about what are the new generations of
storage management systems that were
going to be needed when you have these
visual workloads and one thing that we
realized at that point is most of the
applications using metadata and visual
data to run some processing and in
and in fuel some applications
essentially rely on metadata and visual
data at the same time and the way that
they were doing things was on one side
they were storing metadata using a
relational database or a graph database
Bigwater flavor you want things up any
other database that are already provided
in the cloud they had a separate service
for storing the images that they were
running analytics on such as a regular
HTTP server a distributed file system or
a PAC system accessing something very
specific to storing medical images for
example but these applications were
using these very Taylor components to
deal with this kind of data in this case
visual images in order to run any
machine learning over visual data you
essentially have to apply some
pre-processing steps first so they were
using open CV or even already some of
the functionalities that come integrated
with tensor flow or cafe to run that
pre-processing over the images things
like cropping resizing flipping rotating
images and these applications end up
eluded looking at like a very big Taylor
set of scripts that they needed to do
all these things and make all these
happens go check on the database on the
relational database to get some of the
metadata that they need all the labels
that they need and then go and pick the
images and use that and pass that
through in your net worth and store the
results maybe run some operations using
feature vectors because they extracted
that they build an index using some of
the in-memory libraries that are out
there and then they were throwing away
those indexes because they were just
rebuilding every time so we figured that
we needed a new solution for this in a
way a new data management system that
was oriented towards visual data in
order to unify all these functionalities
that are needed in partitioning separate
tools in a way that it's easy to use
scalable and not just a set of scripts
that if one person no longers maintain
them it becomes really hard to replicate
whatever happened there we also realized
that most of our workloads were going to
be our
official intelligence and machine
learning type of workloads and more
importantly when you have this kind of
workloads you start doing some
inferencing and your the amount of
metadata that you have or the kind of
information that your metadata contains
evolves over time so you start with
images I don't know with dogs and cats
and then you realize you can have build
a new detector where you start getting
people in cars and you want to have a
way to store all that metadata
information in a way that it's gonna
evolve easily so V DMS oriented
specifically to handle visual data and
by visual data I mean both visual they
both things like images or frames in a
video but also the information that you
can extract out out of those such as
feature vectors that you can you can
extract right you can run phase
detection and do feature vector
extraction and get that information as
part of as part of the application and
things are becoming large-scale they
have a lot of information a lot of
metadata you can make use to refine your
models and make the application cover
more corner cases and it's very oriented
towards machine learning and data
science uses PD the idea is that vdm has
tried to address these these challenges
into an integrated solution so we
presented videos last year in this very
same venue we went little bit deeper on
each of the different components that we
have I'm skipping that and just jumping
into the main capabilities we have and
some of the new features that we have
added in the in the newest release so
for taking care of the metadata we use
one of the one of the capabilities PDMS
provides is efficient completion of
metadata queries we do that by using a
graph database that is optimized for
persistent memory this is a very cool
separate project on its own that started
at Inter labs as well and is a design
from scratch graph database that it's
acid compliant it was designed for
persistent memory we are using that
because we realized that a craft
database was the right answer
for storing the type of data that
usually comes with visual information
which is highly connected data the other
very big component of capability of PDMS
is this ability to efficiently store and
retrieve visual data and by visual data
we have as of today we basically support
three types of principal visual data
which are images images can be stored in
regular format such as JPEGs PNG is you
can interact with them we also design
our new format based on an array
database that allows operations or
pre-processing operations to run much
faster one of those operations that work
very much faster than in regular
encodings is cropping I can go into more
detail later but essentially we enable
add query time as you are running
queries into V DMS to apply this
pre-processing operations such as crop
resize or basic augmentation operations
such as flipping rotating the images and
and things that are necessary for the
pre-processing we've also added the
ability to deal with feature vectors or
visual descriptors and essentially you
can create an index of those and start
pushing new feature vectors into the
into the database and then run queries
that involve doing similarity matching
essentially nearest neighbor search
right and you can run that nearest
neighbor search over a over a collection
of feature vectors that you have stored
in a database and at the same time run
some metadata queries on top of that and
I'm gonna be showing an example later so
you understand better what is the idea
but this is a very cool new feature that
we have added recently and we are
working now and we have some basic
support on on starting videos directly
essentially in in the case of videos we
are just providing a limit on the
unlimited data functionality that we
already providing on
and layering on top of operations that
are provided by open CV or some other
library that already solved that problem
the other main thing about VD m s is
that we put a lot of effort in having a
straightforward Klein interface and
Vidya meses Engine is a client-server
architecture and we work very hard in
making a very consistent and easy-to-use
interface in order to interact with the
metadata and the visual data that you
have stored we essentially submit
queries using JSON and it's very easy to
wrap around that in any language that
that you want to create the client side
of of PDMS some example of a typical
pipeline involving PDMS and which
essentially involves the use of both
metadata and visual data you have a
client that is running some machine
learning pipeline or analytics and you
have server that contains both the
metadata and all your visual information
in a single place and through that
client you specify query to get both
metadata and visual data right in this
example that we have done with respect
to doing brain tumor segmentation using
brain scans this was essentially the
pipeline were getting labels and the
actual images passing them through a
machine learning processing that that is
application specific and then pushing
that data back into PDMS or pushing the
result of that computation back to PDMS
in order to retrieve that later we
recently released a version 2.0 on
github PDMS released 2.0 which added a
new but a lot of new features with
respect to what we presented last year
right now we support more complex
operations over the metadata and and
queries related to both the relationship
between the different entities that you
can be living in in your database
in doing more constraint search into
that metadata we support the ability to
store and deal with feature vectors
videos and bounding boxes natively
through our interface and we we added
more operations that were needed for
different proof of concepts that we have
going on through the through the year so
all of these is github right now so you
can just download it and we have docker
images there you can just download that
and start using BDMS right away
one minute all right so one of the
latest features that we have added which
we believe is pretty relevant to many of
the visual applications and you might
have is the ability to deal with these
feature vectors and one of the
applications that we have is doing this
tracking of people doing multi tracking
through multi camera and the way that
that use case work essentially you can
run a person detection over the frames
doing feature vector extraction on that
and pushing that into V DMS and later on
when that person is moving you can do
feature vector extraction again over the
person and in this this time query
whether whether that person exists on
your database or not to keep the
tracking of the person in be DMS can
give you the answer for that so we have
implemented all these new functionality
and we have that running and and going
on on the latest version of V DMS and
finally the one thing that we have been
working on in the last year is the
integration of PDMS with some other
components in order to provide a more
comprehensive solution when it comes to
the processing of visual information
from edge to cloud and we are creating
interfaces to integrate v DM s with two
other projects that are one is sap which
is the streaming analytics framework
that came out of CMU and the scanner
project that came out of Stanford for
doing visual processing and we're
working on on the integration of these
and in applications that that required
both components so more information here
last year we submitted paper at the
assistance for machine learning workshop
nibs we have that paper it has a lot of
information about the new features on
PDMS and more performance evaluation so
yeah how much if any of this is done on
streaming that you know you talk about
feature extraction I can imagine typing
that into a sequel light screening
processor and do some filtering on the
features in addition to whatever you're
doing on the ml pipeline so it really
depends on on how you structure the
application but we do have some examples
in which we are doing this in a
streaming environment so one project
that we have online is using video MS
and one of the other projects for
processing streamings streams of videos
in the context of a retail and we are
essentially querying on real-time BDMS
to do this feature vector matching to
recognize clients or customers that are
returning to the store and that is an
acid as a videos and real-time so we can
do as fast as the rest of the pipeline
is able to process those video streams
that's where most of the challenge is
right now hello thanks to Ana's so as I
said my name is Torsten I work for Smith
like in product management and I was
talking with Phil about what what kind
of content should I cover in the
presentation going back and forth and
probably that what we figured out would
be the most interesting is to go over
some of the main concepts main
techniques that we're using in the core
service in the core engine that sits
behind snowflake if you don't know what
is snowflake so we are essentially the
company that tries to build the data
warehouse for the cloud founded in 2012
we are headquartered down close to San
Francisco Airport in San Mateo we have
development offices up here in Bellevue
Washington and in Berlin Germany I
started when the company was just shy of
200 employees two years ago we are now
above
1,000 employees and among those 150 plus
are in core engineering and obviously we
are hiring our three main founders two
of them benoit Dodgeville and terry
Corrales has spent 10 20 years at Oracle
and then Marcin Sikorsky has come from
the startup side vector vise and other
places for those that are have been at
Microsoft for some time the name Bob
Moog leas probably a familiar one
he's our CEO we we went public with the
general availability of our service in
2015 and since then raised a bunch of
money which is good but also scary so
our product is essentially an elastic
data warehouse it's a multi-tenant
system transactional highly secure and
it does not depend on any of the usual
suspects in that space or either
Postgres or any of the hadoop system so
it's a built from scratch we currently
supports two cloud providers that we use
for both storage and compute aw yes and
since last year Microsoft Azure as well
even the order of six or seven regions
built out across the globe and across
all of those we have in the order of
tens of petabytes of customer data that
we store running millions of queries
from our customers each and every day
our current customer base has about 1500
customers that are working on the system
on a daily basis and that is growing
fast so what are some of the key things
that we aspire to so the first one is we
want to provide our data warehouse
offering as a cloud service and probably
closes that you can think about this is
software as a service you walk up to
something like Salesforce as a user and
data warehousing should be as simple as
that
in terms of that the second pillar than
E is elasticity so we want to give you
the ability to store at store as much
data as you can possibly think and then
put as much analytics and compute on top
of that and scale both of them
independently of each other and third
but not last we also want to support all
kinds of data so the traditional
relational structured table format data
but also semi structured data
that you find in a number of application
scenarios and you want to do that with
with native support in the storage
engine so swimming into you this stack
at the top level this is how the
snowflake stack looks like you can think
about it essentially as three layers at
the bottom you have this storage layer
and there we are just using regular blob
storage in the cloud as a blob storage
or s3 for the to cloud providers if you
currently work with on top of that
customers are running what we call
virtual warehouses so where a virtual
warehouse is essentially a cluster of
compute nodes powered by virtual
machines in cloud computing that that
works with the data that's that stored
in the storage layer and then as careers
retrieve data builds up a cache which
sits on the local disks in each virtual
warehouse and as a customer I can access
any data that sits down here given you
have the appropriate permissions and
then put as much compute on top of it as
you need so one of the key scenarios
that we support is if you have different
workloads for instance for different
departments in your organization you can
give them differently sized virtual
warehouses that all operate over the
same shared data so at this point in the
middle here this is not multi tenant but
switching up to the top level the cloud
services up here which take care of
transaction management career
optimization concurrency control
security and so on this is a multi
tenant service that we implement and
that's kind of the front door that every
query every request comes in
so now zooming in to the various layers
here so remember these these three areas
here that we talked about and starting
at the bottom essentially with the
storage layer the key here is we are
just using regular blob storage in AWS
or Azure it's an object store key value
store it's extremely highly available
very durable it comes with certain
performance penalties from a latency
perspective obviously because you have
to go across the network to to get your
data it's also append only from a
workload perspective so you cannot
override an object in place which is
interesting implications so if you're
thinking about all TP workloads they're
probably not a good
but for analytics workloads where you
continuously incrementally add data
that's usually a good fit for these
kinds of scenarios and that you'll see
that has a number of implications and
also later on as we talk about
concurrency control so that's kind of
the basic ingredient from a storage
perspective the structure that we put on
top of that is what we call table files
and we are using the columnar
representation for the data it goes into
a table file and it's a variation of the
packs model and every table that stored
in snowflake is horizontally partitioned
across a number of these table files
each table file is roughly sixteen
megabyte in size and uses that a
columnar representation and then are
kind of as a side system independent of
the blob storage to cloud storage we are
using FTB to you manage our metadata and
in that FTP system we retaining the
information which table files belong to
what particular table and as the query
comes in then we touch the metadata
that's it sits in FDB and we figure out
what table version corresponds to what
files and then the crepe goes and and
processes those files okay so with that
we're moving up one level in this stack
and you can see that at that little icon
at the top right so we're switching over
to you virtual warehouses a virtual
warehouse as I mentioned is essentially
just a set of virtual machines in cloud
compute and it's a pure compute resource
that is stateless at least initially
until we've build up a cache and we can
size it independently and for even the
same data set we can create as many of
these virtual warehouses as needed for
for customer we can shut them down if
the customer are is essentially running
an idle workload and it comes in various
different t-shirt sizes so essentially
an extra small warehouse maps to a
single node a single VM and then we can
go up to hundreds of VMs all kind of
processing in a scale out fashion to
queries that you're sending in to them
the user does not necessarily know what
nodes are being run all of that is
abstracted behind this t-shirt size
concept as I mentioned for performance
reasons we we hang on to the files to
the data that we load from remote
storage so we build up that cash it's a
collection of the table files that we
keep locally the tables files that we
that we just talked about what's
interesting is that the nodes in the
same cluster can steal files from each
other if they have been loaded into
another machine I can go essentially to
my neighbor and ask for data that the
neighbor may have but I don't have cool
so on these on these virtual machines in
the virtual warehouse we are running the
core execution engine for all intents
and purposes it just purely focuses on
processing queries remember all the
query optimization all the transaction
management all the security is done at
the top level at the global service is
little and I want to call it a few of
the kind of key ideas that are play here
so as you probably figured from the
table file structure we are using a
color processing approach here like
monitor B or C store and and that gives
us a good baseline for performance
margin zhukovsky is one of our founders
so don't be surprised if you see
vectorized query processing show up here
as well so we are making use of that
we're not using volcano at our radius so
we're using a push based approach that's
it's based on Norman and that works
pretty well at least in in our in our
case so and as I mention no transaction
management is done at this level that's
all taken care of at the top level and
we will talk about that in just a minute
now most of the operators try to
leverage and do as much as possible in
in memory but they have the ability to
just bill to disk to the local disks on
the machines or even s3 or or as a blob
storage if that is needed so moving up
to the top level here so that's the
cloud services level how we call it
it's a collection of different services
access control security career
optimization concurrency control
transaction management that's uh that's
really the first place where our system
is multi truly multi tenant the virtual
warehouses that do the query execution
they're all dedicated to a specific
tenant to a specific customer and the
obviously that the multi-tenancy brings
a number of interesting challenges for
us so we have to make sure it's secure
that every ten in the sandbox
that's highly available it could be a
single point of failure so all of these
aspects are just amplified for us in in
this cloud services level and that's
also the place where we then heavily
interact also with this metadata store
that I mentioned it has all the
knowledge about the files and they're in
their content so let's start with
concurrency control two of our founders
are coming from Oracle so you shouldn't
be too surprised if you are if you're
seeing a multi-version concurrency
control approach that's being applied
here in snapchat isolation so all
concepts very very similar to to what
you will find in Oracle that also is
very natural for us if you think about
the file based approach it's very easy
for us to think about snapshots
essentially as versions of a table where
each version of a table is represented
by a set of files that accurate for a
table at any given point in time and
that then allows us to point an incoming
query to a very specific set of files
which then implements a version of a
table it's also very handy if you for
instance want to do cloning for tables
it's a metadata only operation and you
can also then offer things like time
travel that we that we heard before by
going back to previous versions off of a
table yep
so in terms of query processing probably
the key aspect I want to mention here is
the ability to to brew to prune so
what's the fastest way to process data
and what I say is don't process it in
the in the first place so
the idea here is to figure out for any
incoming query what did I do actually
needs to touch to provide you with a
correct and accurate result to the query
in order to do that we are not relying
on indexes because that typically has a
big burden for users because you have to
decide which indexes to create and then
we have to maintain them what we are
doing instead is as data is being loaded
we extracting metadata and statistics
for the incoming table files and we are
retaining that in our metadata as a new
query comes in and we look at that
metadata and decide whether a particular
table file may qualify for the query or
not and if it doesn't qualify then we
are pruning that from from the
processing you can see there are a
number of different statistics that we
are retaining in the metadata to do this
this kind of pruning so with all of this
what are the ongoing challenges for us
obviously scale is a big topic for us so
we have to go into additional regions
across the globe to meet our customers
wherever they are the customer data is
increasing the metadata is growing so
scale and managing scale is a big big
topic for us we need to wrap our head
around server less computing low latency
streaming data ingestion is is a topic
that's interesting to us as well then
something fairly unique which we offer
is the capability to share data and
collaborate over data so that's an
investment big investment area for us
but besides that there there's just
typical traditional database work that
needs to be done across the stack and
with that let me wrap it up thanks very
much
[Applause]
questions for tourists uh what is the
motion I think for your MMC C and how do
you ensure that you have the you have
the correct you had matching version IDs
macros tables ODB make sure so there's
this this is time stamp based
essentially you're getting a time stamp
on the different tables in there and a
table version for for a given table is
represented by a timestamp so if you
have you come in and you you run a query
it's essentially you're getting whatever
is read committed on that on that
particular table different tables will
have different time because of the time
because of clock period and then that
may you may not able to correct snapshot
well remember that the metadata is
maintained in f DB which is fully
transactional so even if your
transaction is maintaining or updating
multiple tables there's this there's a
single transaction that goes into into
our metadata stores so that you can
attach the same timestamp to all the
tables that are touched by a transaction
which a warehouse is pertinent is that
what you mean by your tenant that's
correct so a customer actually goes in
and says I want for this particular
workload I want to run or I want to back
this by the following set of resources
that can be a single cluster of machines
but the cluster can also scale to
multiple clusters for high concurrency
scenarios and then that set of resources
is dedicated to that particular customer
which is not the case for the top-level
filter do you for the those those on
virtual warehouses do you do an SLA
based pricing and then elastic scale and
in scale out under some priced envelope
or is there much more static at this
point it's fairly static we'd love to
get into I'd say a more dynamic model
here where essentially you throw aquaria
at us and we figure out how much
resources
do do you need for that may be given
some pricing constraints or some
performance aspirations that's not
something that we do yet at this point
automatically push how does it work for
joints for you that's a great question I
don't know from the top of my head
that's something that I would would
would get you in touch with Marcin or or
Alice and from our sequel team okay this
thing Torsten again we come to our last
event of the day the closing keynote by
Donald and Arvind in terms of quick
reduction Donal is currently the
director of MSR Redmond used to be
professor at ETA and recently moved to
the MSR maybe in three four years three
years ago
Arvind is the researcher in the nativist
group here who has widely published
across a variety of issues such as data
security you need us to be focusing and
they're going to talk about four legs
really database applications or not
launching so it has one of the reason
the buzzwords in it yes can you can you
hear me yeah okay so usually the last
speakers the lat is I'm between you and
dinner or something really great right I
am now between you and chaos right so
whatever that means whether this is
makes it even worse I know that you
cannot wait until you can park your car
148th Avenue but so I'll try to get you
there
to your traffic jam as fast as possible
so so what I'm going to talk about
blockchains which is kind of like a
cooling down a little bit so maybe this
is a good moment in time to to reflect
and step a little bit back and what I
will present you is a little bit our
point of view not necessarily
Microsoft's point of view but Microsoft
Research or of one particular project
there it has that we've been working on
in this space so
maybe the most important slide is this
slide and that is what is it that we
want to achieve with blockchain or why
are we interested in blockchain so
blockchain does many things right and
and and that's going to be an important
part of this tour kind of factoring out
the things that we believe are useful
and the things that we believe are less
useful and then somehow packaging it
together so I what we believe is why
blockchain is great is because it
provides you proof of something that you
have done or that somebody else has done
yeah and so it's a proof of that
something happened in the digital world
another way to look at it is blockchain
is in some way electronic or digital
form of the witness yeah so in the real
world proof is well if I if I promise
you I'm gonna pay you a beer right then
you probably are going to hold me
accountable for it and you're gonna use
everybody else as witness and say well
Donald really said that
yeah and that's what you're gonna going
to use to kind of make sure that I
really pay the beer yeah so in the real
world proof and witnesses are a normal
thing and they happen all the time and
that's why we believe it's also a
concept that is very useful in the
digital world and blockchain is a is a
component a technology component that
doesn't and that's what we're going to
talk about so just to to give this
perspective why this is useful why
witnesses are useful essentially
everything that you do in the real world
or a lot of things that you do in the
real world require proof yeah so I'm
married and with that I kind of I
sometimes say tell my wife yeah we are
married you should be nice to me right
and and I can prove that because yeah I
we have a certificate actually I don't
have a ring anymore because I lost it
but that that is often the
and you have witnesses like the best man
what we will also see is the kind of
simple examples are like you're buying
alcohol I'm always very proud when when
I when I go into a bar and people ask me
for my driver's license it unfortunately
doesn't happen that often but in the
digital world as we will see it's it's
not that easy to prove that you're 18
years old and that you can buy alcohol
on the web right this is something where
you want to provide proof in the real
world we have things and arvin is going
to tell and talk about the digital form
of a driver's license we have these
artifacts to provide proof and this is
exactly what we want to do in the in the
digital world now so why do we want to
and why is this coming up now yeah and
this is essentially because of the cloud
era right in the old era now as a next
I'll give another example just to put it
into perspective in the PC world right
when you were kind of a loan on your PC
and you were playing pacman right you
were not really you didn't really need
proof yeah if you've got a new high
score in pac-man maybe you wanted to
kind of show off at at work and say I
got a new high score and usually you did
that by taking of a screenshot but on
the PC in the old PC area when you were
alone and you were the only person kind
of curating your data proof was not that
important but now we live in the cloud
world where and we live in the connected
world where people collaborate yeah
where people and I'm going to use Excel
as a next in the next slide where people
collaborate to produce content and then
indeed you want to have proof you want
to know where data comes from and that's
because you make decision based on the
data that is that you're looking at so
let me just give a small example of our
favorite database here at Microsoft
Excel yeah and so again in the old world
you type
your data and you trusted yourself and
you trusted what you want to do but in
the new world this Excel spreadsheets
the information might come from
different sources so let's assume you're
Britney Spears and you're interested to
to find out who are you going to date
tonight right and and so you have this
spreadsheet and and if you're Britney
Spears you might want to be interested
to know where this information comes
from particularly of course this age
information because of course you want
to you don't want to date any of those
really old guys right and so for Britney
Spears it might be interesting to know
that two of these kind of ages they come
from from Bing and one comes from from
wishful thinking so this is really what
we are talking about here and this is
where we want to kind of get blocked in
and in some sense this is a database
yeah
so essentially what the the goal of what
we are trying to achieve and how why
we're using these technologies the goal
is really that we want to automate this
this kind of generating proofs and of
course there's no proof here that Tom
Cruise is 55 the proof is this
information came from bing and what we
want to generate a proof for is that
this information came from from visual
thinking or manual entry yeah and so the
the the the bottom line of this is that
blockchain is actually a very nice
building block of generating these
proofs and with these proofs essentially
trust but it is not enough yeah and
because and and the way and this is kind
of the the message here the way
blockchain is packaged today is is it is
not the right way right so in the
project and really what we're working on
is about repackaging it in a form that
we actually get this proof without
reinventing everything else
and reinventability okay so what is this
talk and a do once we're done and here
is chaos here's traffic jam down here so
I'll give you a very brief I assume most
of you know what blockchain is but I I
still want to kind of introduce sort of
the very basic concepts of blockchain so
because we're going to decompose it and
recompose it again so I'll do that at
the beginning then I'll tell you a
little bit how kind of the blueprint how
we are repackaging it and actually the
more interesting thing is because this
is all very abstract is arvind is then
going to tell you about one and a very
fairly sophisticated system that we have
that we implement it with this with this
blueprint let's put it that way
and that is a system called
decentralized ID it's it's actually a
standard but that is actually doing
something really useful yeah this is
think of it as replacing login with
Facebook with something that you can
control and that that is totally
distributed and and open okay does that
sound like a good plan
yeah now is a good moment to to stop me
okay so switching back into into kind of
cruise mode so this is this is what
blockchain is again I assume that most
of you know and what it is but it is
essentially two concepts which are
coupled together and the first concept
is where all the crypto is is is making
things immutable yeah so once you've
done something a transaction I'll just
give a small example of that nobody can
change it anymore yeah and the second
thing is is this concept of the witness
that I said before technically what it
is is it's a consensus protocol and of
course that's where all the variety is
and when you when you look at all the
innovation they're good gazillions of
different consensus protocols with with
different properties and scalability
cost and so on scalability in the number
of
users versus scalability in the number
of transactions and and the size of the
data and that's where all these
differences and these two are kind of
baked together yeah and as I will argue
that this baking these two things
together that's what makes it actually
work in blockchain but it's actually not
needed and the main message that I'm
giving is if you kind of decouple the
two yeah
then actually you can you can achieve
pretty much the same guarantees and this
proof guarantees but you can integrate
it in a in a better way so for example
for consensus and we database people
have have have also a good story and so
if you want to use your your your
database system kind of to order
transaction you can use it
whereas in blockchain essentially this
ordering of transactions is baked into
the consensus protocol which is for
database people not the best thing to do
okay so these are the two concepts baked
together and I'll just show this through
an example how this is exposed and and
and and and I think everybody
understands so Amy is actually our
Microsoft chief financial officer and
Harry is kind of the big shepherd harry
shum of of microsoft research and so
let's say you have kind of the situation
is that amy has 70 million bitcoins and
harry has 50 million bitcoins and then
Amy gives Harry 20 million bitcoins and
because Harry was so great in the next
step Amy gives Harry 30 million bitcoins
so at the end
Amy will have 20 million and Harry will
have 50 million and the problem that
blockchain addresses and that's the
first thing is with the immutability is
well let's say Harry just kind of
because he has access this is lives in
the cloud and this is just data in the
cloud and Harry is kind of smart and he
kind of got hand of a copy of this data
where this is stored and he changes the
20 to the 50 and the problem is
this point and in this situation nobody
neither a me can prove that this was a
20 nor Harry can prove that this is a 50
yeah there is no information there's
nothing there right and that's the
problem that blockchain addresses yeah
and so how does it address it and this
is exactly these two things baked
together it addresses it by by having
witnesses yeah and these witnesses in
the in the Bitcoin blockchain is just
the the whole community of everybody
around and what do these bit these
witnesses keep they essentially keep a
picture a photo or thumbnail of what you
want to do of the of the head of the
blockchain and every block in the
blockchain keeps a picture of the
previous block yeah and this is our
blockchain work so now if if hair each
kind of messes around with this picture
essentially this picture this thumbnail
or this hash of this block they they
will not match anymore and at this point
everybody will know that this is not the
right version of the block and so in
some sense hair Amy if she has the old
version of this or the correct version
of this she can prove that these two
much and the Hat and Harry will not be
able to do this again creating proof for
transactions that is what we that's what
we are interested in here okay of course
Harry might be smart and might want to
also kind of change this picture so that
it matches here but in this case then
the the witnesses and their copy it the
this this block will will not match the
picture of the the block that the the
witnesses have or the hash of that okay
and this is how it this is okay I think
everybody understands this and this is
all well known so now let's step back as
database people this is our traditional
world we have an application and we have
a database system and we read and write
using sequel
into that database system and this is
the world we love and I think most of
the day we've heard about this wall and
this is now the new world that I've just
described here and you can of course
build applications on top of that and
that's a little bit what we are
interested in and we will show one of
these example applications but now if
you look at it our our API has changed
our API is not well the sequel and you
might want to make it sequel but there
are some some some more fundamental
thing the the update in place or update
doesn't exist anymore right and it's
fundamental that the update doesn't
exist now you can say well we've heard
ins in and I think Marsha I said well
you don't update either right you you
just append but in some sense logically
you still have an update right here that
doesn't exactly exist it's read and
append and it is the abstraction is that
of a ledger it's not of that of a table
right but you have something else that
is very important you have a verify
operation create a proof yeah create a
proof that this transaction Amy gave
Harry 20 exists and you can do that in
this world but you cannot do that in
this world at least not in our sequel
databases that we have today yeah so you
have this kind of great kind of creating
proof property here and and you have the
great kind of productivity performance
also all the other kind of things this
is a very well-established ecosystem and
very well optimized and and well tested
and robust environment so the goal that
we essentially have is that we want to
combine the two and this is what I will
show you kind of one way how to do that
at a very schematic way but then the the
more interesting way is how this is
working in a very large-scale system and
Arvind will tell you about that so
essentially what we want to achieve is
that your application is pretty much
unchanged
yeah you still use sequel you still use
the same abstractions but that we have
to build these abstract the these
applications and you also want your
database system to perform in the same
way you want to have the same
availability you want to see it have the
same durability you want to have the
same performance guarantees you want to
use be trees if that is what you what
you love to index the data but then on
the other hand you want to and this is
the kind of ID the idea here is you want
to still have this verify functionality
you still want to be able to create
proofs and this is what we want to
achieve and I'm going to give you a very
for the next three minutes before Ivan
comes I'm going to give you a kind of a
blueprint of how this can be done and of
course the technical details are a
little bit more complicated but
essentially you should get from this
blueprint also a feeling of that this
actually does work and is possible
so here's the idea I'll skip kind of the
essentially the idea is to decouple the
witnessing and the immutability yeah and
so I'll just explain this so again you
have a me you have your database with
your balances with your with your
balances Amy has 70 and Harry has 50 and
again your goal is you want to you want
to kind of do these transactions in the
traditional way using sequel you want
them to perform as as before but you
want to be able to create proofs on the
side and the way to do that is okay Amy
does this transaction again in the same
way as she did before and then what you
do is you start creating essentially
this lock chain or this tamper proof log
or how you want to however you want to
call it you enter this Amy this
transaction into there and but you don't
kind of verify just at this point yet
all right you put it there but what you
also give you give Amy a receipt and
that's the kind of the idea because this
receipt is important if this receipt is
lost in some sense Amy
will not be able to later prove that
anything has happened here in the
blockchain yeah so you give this receipt
and this is essentially to make sure
that this database that you don't trust
here you don't trust anything that is in
this cloud right all of this can be none
and even this component that creates
this cryptographic hashes here and again
those are the details you have to look
into the paper that can all be hacked
and fraud with but Amy can can at least
verify that this receipt matches to her
to her transaction so you do this and
you operate this and this is the only
additional overhead that you have in the
inner loop and and it's fairly cheap you
create these cryptographic hashes and of
course you have to log everything and
you log essentially while you log you
create these these these block chains
with the with a with the secure hashes
that they are not tampered with and so
what does Amy do with this and she does
that a synchronously she gives this
receipt to her witness and again I'm not
saying anything here about permission
blockchain of public blockchain the blue
pledge should be general and independent
of that so this would work for here this
is maybe a more kind of private
environment where the Terry is one of
the board members of of Microsoft where
there's kind of a closed set of
witnesses but this could also be an open
set of witnesses where you just publish
your receipt and put it on some kind of
BitTorrent protocol to disseminate it
yeah and so with these receipts now
these witnesses and again of course this
doesn't have to be people those are
agents that can run anywhere this could
run in the Amazon Cloud and this could
be in the Microsoft cloud or the other
way around
they can now verify with these receipts
that everything here happens and the
beauty of this kind of architecture is
are first of all this is a synchronous
it doesn't doesn't interrupt in the
thing and it's very flexible you can you
can decide only to verify when
something bad happens and if never said
anything bad happens you never pay the
price for it yeah
but if something bad happens you always
have everything that you need all these
receipts or whatever you want to prove
that something went wrong and I'll just
give some very simple examples let's say
Harry wants to change this and of course
the receipts will not match here and
this will be caught but also what will
be caught is if if Harry changes
something here she says well no I I have
actually 100 million hundred million
bitcoins
and if he changes that actually that
will be caught at some point when when
Amy actually reads starts reading this
at the point where this will be read
actually that will reads will also
create receipts and at that point the
receipts that are created here will not
match again okay so that's the blueprint
and essentially the bottom line is that
there's an there's a very important
technology building block it's just
packaged in the wrong way and with that
I want to give it to Arvind to kind of
go through a fairly sophisticated system
that was essentially build with this
kind of mindset Emma
[Applause]
so can people hear me
so thank you Donald and thank you your
harness for the introduction so I'll be
talking about one of the very concrete
example of some of the ideas that Donald
mentioned so and in this case you see
that for one particular application
application space you will see how we
can overlay an existing system on top of
block chains to achieve like verifiable
to guarantee so you can verify whether
who is doing what and if something goes
wrong and you can find out like what is
the reason for it right so okay so so I
start off with this very famous and I
should mention that lot of these ideas
we worked with other people in other
parts of Microsoft from the identity
team I should just mention you anyway so
whilst we'll start off with this very
famous cartoon so in this cartoon it
says that you have this couple of dogs
and you one of them says on the internet
you can do anything like no one knows
you're a dog but sometimes we want to
know that you're a dog so for example it
might be ordering some pizza place or
something like that so you actually want
to know is that all right so so like
jokes apart like one of the like what
like one of the problems that we have is
the identity is a fundamental notion on
the web right so for many of the
examples that Donald mentioned earlier I
want to show that I'm above a certain
age therefore I can have alcohol so we
need to like make facts about ourselves
and in in a digital world we need to be
able to do it in a formal sense we want
to show that this is actually the case
right so a central notion for many of
these things the witness's ideas is is
an idea of an identity right like more
formally what is identity right so like
my identity for example is it consists
of my personal information name my age
the date of birth and information about
which country I belong to my citizenship
and education occupation skills and so
on right and what is identity problem
much more formally the the identity
problem or is basically it is it's the
problem of coming up with mechanisms to
show like certain attributes about
myself to variety of systems so for
example when I when I enter the country
and it
to show that I'm a citizen of this
country when I when I when I use my car
I need to be able to show that I have
that it could I have the requisite
driving skills to use my car I'm not so
sure about this weather though but in
general I have that and and and the
second problem over this identity is the
above mechanisms should also ensure that
it should not be possible for someone
else to impersonate me as far as his
identity is concerned like like someone
else should not pretend that he or she
is Arvind and then impersonate me right
so we want to ensure these two
properties one is we want to show that
we are us and we have this properties
and then we want our others from
impersonating me so if you observe
what's happening online like how is this
problem being solved today right so so
what we have now is not one identity
system but we have a whole patchwork of
systems right and some of the identities
are like license your passport these are
like physical artifacts that I should
buy say in this case the US government
and you also have identities like your
IDs in your login IDs in LinkedIn
Facebook Google Microsoft and the banks
and so on right so essentially and then
if you if you look at this identify us
on the left these are all like online
identifiers which means that they're
essentially a password and a username
and and basically put together they try
to solve the problem that I mentioned
earlier right so for example when I
enter the country I can show my password
I can show my passport to enter this
building I have a badge and so on and so
forth and also notice that many of these
identities also rely on this physical
documents like the university that you
went to you it might issue a physical
and Tipler my and so on right so we can
use this mishmash of technologies to
show certain properties about ourselves
that I went to I have this education has
the skills and so on and so forth but
but it comes with a whole whole set of
problems so like what are the problems
so first of all I don't own any of these
identifiers that are issued by the
system I can't generate a new identifier
if I want to I need to relay on some
other system to generate that interfere
for me so I don't want any of these
things and and because I rely on
existing systems often this existing
systems have centralized route of trust
so all the identifiers that we have
today
they rely on centralized route of trust
so if I need an island from Google I am
I'm trusting Google to manage identity
for me and because it is like
centralized it's not universally
accepted so Microsoft is not gonna
accept an identity from Google and vice
versa so so like what happens of this is
because because of this is we have the
problem that we have a whole whole set
of identifiers and which increases the
management complexity of because of that
anyone can identify with the problem of
managing hundreds of logins and you know
passwords for all these logins and so on
and and also the identifiers that we
have today the identity that the notions
of identity that we have today are or
non cryptographic which means that I
cannot I cannot formally show some
property about myself so these are not
rooted in cryptography but in a variety
of ad hoc mechanisms and in particular
this makes it very easy for someone to
impersonate me right for any of these
identifiers if I lose my my password and
log like login name and potentially some
attributes about myself like someone
else can impersonate me very easily
right and also this non cryptographic
nature makes it easy it makes it hard to
to achieve privacy so for example if I
want to show that I am a boy a certain
age I'll show what do I do today I will
show my license but the license contains
a variety of other information like my
residence which I don't want to reveal I
just want to reveal that I am over 21
right I don't want to reveal my exact
date of birth my residence and and so on
so forth it's very hard to achieve with
the existing systems ok so in the rest
of the talk I want to argue I want to
basically speak about one idea the idea
about three centralized identifiers and
essentially it the vision of this
identifier is that it's a self owned
identity which is owned by you which can
be used to securely and privately store
all elements of your identity and all
attributes about yourself right so let
me unpack the statement for you right so
first of all such an identity is three
centralized it's not relying on like
Microsoft or any particular organization
to keep a service up and running for you
to produce an identity and then and so
on right and anyone can the vision is
that anyone can concept an identity and
use it and the second issue is that the
the the
the second aspect is that because there
is no centralized root of trust it's
completely decentralized it potentially
like it it has a potential to minimize
the need for a large number of like
separate identify identifiers right so
this is a vision so because it's if it
is it's completely non centralized it
can be Universal and everyone can accept
this mission and and in fact I want to
argue that the vision that I laid out is
not a vision that is specific to
Microsoft it's not a vision that we came
up with it's a vision that is part of an
organization called a centralized
identity foundation and a whole bunch of
companies are already part of this
organization including Microsoft and IBM
and a whole bunch of companies and I
think the last time I checked Facebook
and Google were not there but whole
bunch of companies are there and also as
we will see with an example that the
identity that we have here is
cryptographic which means that we can
use protocols cryptographic protocols
for authentication and establishing
claims as an example right okay so oops
the animation is not right okay okay
so the that so this idea of a
centralized ID that I presented itself
is a very high level specification that
is there in the organization but what we
are doing in Microsoft is to produce a
specific protocol that conforms to the
high level specification and in this
example in this running example I will I
will basically flesh out what the
protocol looks like and how it can be
used to address like some of the
problems that we mentioned earlier so as
I mentioned earlier like and in fact
your protocol that we are building is
called site 3 it's an internal name it's
it's not ok so anyway a society is a p2p
protocol which means that anyone can run
a site or a node and as and this
protocol itself is not it's a
second-level protocol which means that
it is kind of built on top of an
existing blockchain like a Bitcoin so in
this case all the origin nodes are the
site rate notes and the Bitcoin network
is like shown in blue and any two cited
nodes are essentially communicating with
each other using the Bitcoin network so
and which means that all the sites or
information that we will see will
basically be
we'll be serialized as part of the
Bitcoin of Bitcoin tamper-proof Locke
so so we have a user Alice who comes
along Hailey's want to generate an ID so
basically she contacts one of the like
one of her fifth favorite site tree
notes she could run a node by herself
and she has a she has a note to generate
an ID and as part of the process she
also generates a private key for herself
and a public key which she gives as part
of this operation so what the system
does is it constructs a unique
identifier for Alice and it also CH the
public key of Alice with this unique
identifier and the fact that Alice's
identifier and the public key is
basically the so it is basically
embedded anchored in the blockchain so
at some location in the blockchain there
will be an a transaction which records
the fact that you have a particular ID
and ID has a particular public key
associated with this right so this
information is in the blockchain and
because blockchain because of the
blockchain consciousness mechanism every
blockchain node is aware of this
information which means that every site
tree node on the universe will know you
will have a consistent view of the
information that this is an ID and this
a public key associated with sorry about
her age right we'll get to that
that's exactly my example later right so
yes at some point for some reason my
Alice my animation is all screwed up
sorry about that so at some point Alice
can come and say hey this is my ID and
she can do an update operation and she
can come and say my name is Alice and
this is my date of birth and again the
system would blindly accept it assuming
that any such update has to be signed
with her private key which means that
you and I cannot if we are not Alice
unless because we don't possess the
private key that we cannot do the update
but Alice can certainly do the update
and she can say anything about herself
and and that information would be also
kind of like yeah you eventually
anchored in the blockchain right so this
would be fine
as Ted mentioned it's not very
interesting for a user to make
statements about herself I can say
anything about myself and as I said you
can say you're 28 and you know so that
information will be there but where the
system becomes interesting is that if we
kind of so
like when it becomes interesting is that
if we introduce Network effects so if
everyone is part of the system so
imagine that you have organization your
bank's your so your licensing office all
becomes part of this thing and then you
have say and then you start making
statements about itself each other it
becomes very interesting so as a running
example like will will augment Alice
with University of Washington let's say
University of Washington also becomes
part of the system it gets his own ID
and then at some point this does
licensing department gets his own ID and
then now if you assume that Alice goes
to u-dub and gets a computer science
degree she can go to u-dub and say so
this is my ID and what you would do is
it basically it would attest the fact
that she has a computer science degree
from u-dub and basically it would sign
with its private key and and such a
document it can basically release the
document to Alice and now what Alice can
do is like she can update her ID
information with the fact that she has
this document so she has this diploma
from u-dub
and that information can also go to the
blockchain at this point he can say and
and and likewise read she can go to
licensing office she can show that she
can drive and she get a license and and
that information would also go to the
blockchain at this point he can come and
say hey but blockchain is public
information why are we putting all this
information in the blockchain and the
answer to that is we don't have to put
all this information what we can do is
we can we can basically anchor a hash of
this information in the blockchain so
but Alice can retain ownership of all
this information so she has this license
but the hash of this license go to the
blockchain which means that at some
level because the hash has this one-way
property she is committing herself to
having this document but you don't need
to put the document in the blotching
right so essentially it is like putting
that information in the blockchain but
without any other privacy concerns right
so again this is a very high-level view
one of the properties of like like one
of the innovations of the site tree a
protocol itself is how to make this
efficient I won't be talking about it if
anyone who knows Bitcoin knows that it's
transaction rate is like one transaction
per second and that is totally a
non-starter if we can only do one
transaction per second essentially we
have ideas for we are for combining
multiple transaction as one Bitcoin
transaction and therefore we can achieve
much higher rates
what because suppose anyway so we'll
look at how this system can be used to
show proofs right we are at the end of
the day we are interested in proofs so
so let's assume that Alice goes to a bar
and she wants to convince Bob the
Bartman that her age is about 21 so she
goes and says that hey this is my D
right so she gives the idea to Bob Bob
and what he can do is he C so he can run
his own site or e network or he can go
to city like he can go to some site tree
node and say like what is the public key
of this di D and because this
information is consistent every site
tree node has a consistent view of this
of the universe he gets Alice's public
key that was registered where she
generated the D ID right so that
information he gets accesses document
with Alice's name and so on and and if
you observed yeah I've actually embedded
a hash of her license so he gets a hash
of her driver's license as well right so
and then what happens so he still not
convinced that he's talking to Alice
because it could be anyone who is this
IDs are public information at some level
right so anyone could be saying that
Alice so he says hey I'm not convinced
at your Alice so I want you to show that
you're Alice and this is like fairly
standard cryptography he basically he
constructs a random string and he
requires Alice to sign the random string
with her private key and assuming that
only Alice has possession of the travel
key so Alice would be able to sign and
authenticate herself that she is Alice
right and at that point he knows that
he's talking to Alice he has access to
the Alice public he can verify the
signature using the public key and he
also has the hash of a license at that
point Alice can go and forward a license
to Bob and and he can verify that he
that is indeed he has a license and
she's about to anyone yes and and to
verify that he can also do the same step
again because Alice's license is like
he's like signed by another entity that
the licensing department he can go to
site 3 and get the information from
sightly and verify that the license is
valid so everything is well works so in
fact we can even go further I'm not
going to speak about it we can use some
ideas from like zero knowledge proof to
not reveal the entire license to Bob but
even the fact that Alice's age is about
anyone but let's not get into those
details okay okay so at this point what
I had is a very simple toy example of
how we can show some facts in the system
but then we'll consider like like like
one of the visions that we laid out
earlier in this presentation is that we
can retrofit a lot of this verifiability
to existing platforms so in this case I
want to consider platforms called
Open ID open ID is a pretty well-known
standard and lot of identity providers
like Google ITIN the provider and Active
Directory they kind of rely on this open
ID protocol for identity and how does
open ID ID protocol works so again we
have Alice and Alice says so in this
open ID protocol essentially we have an
ID provider this is a system like Active
Directory or Google ID provider and
Alice who would have an account with
such an ID provider and this ID provider
would have information about Alice that
Alice can access this machine she can
across this printer and she has all this
credentials and what Alice would do is
whenever she wants to access any
resource and in this case and in the in
the open ID protocol like language any
resource that she wants access any
websites that she wants access is called
the dis relying party so what Alice
would do is she would first contact the
ID provider and authenticate herself
using again this is not with the new
ideas this is this is how the world
works today right she would authenticate
ourselves with our ID provider with a
username password or multi-factor
authentication what not right at that
point if the ID provider is convinced
that it is indeed Alice what the ID
provider will do is it'll generate at
token and and this token has protections
and Alice would basically be able to
forward the token to another like
relaying party and and this ruling party
knows at this point that this is Alice
and then and then and then let her use
the services so like what's the problem
with this right it's we have the same
kind of problem that you mentioned
earlier
so this relying party has to trust ID
provider so this ID provider is hacked
for example if someone modifies the
Alice's password inside the ID provider
anyone can and and such a person can log
in as part of the authenticate himself
to the ID provider as Alice and then get
all the access rights
right so essentially we don't have any
proof that anything like that has not
happened so how can we add proofs into
the system so we can basically overlay
the system with the protocol like the
site tree
so essentially what what would happen
now is this ID provider and this this
this relying party would now operate on
site tree in this case I have shown site
tree as a layer that is that is sitting
below so Alice in the beginning of time
when she sets up a knocko and what
happens is she contacts the ID provider
and and the ID provider can issue this
new ID for for Alice in the system but
instead of having a separate a database
of Alice's properties attributes like
what I do provider can do is he can
embed that information as part of the
the the site tree blockchain so this
information about Alice her ID her her
properties were attributes is now
embedded in this layer that is now
sitting below and now Alice at some
later point she can she can contact she
can contact think she can contact the
this relay this relying party and
authenticate because she has the private
key for the new ID and then this relying
party can access all the information
from this layer so like what's the
advantage of this isnow ID provider it
need not be trusted if something goes
wrong the ID provider we have exact you
can verify that something went wrong
right it provided these are all the
rules that ID provider added to this
layer and we have we have we have the
complete lineage of what happened so you
can verify that factor so in fact we can
do something more interesting also I
won't speak a lot about it it kind of
hints that at some of the ideas that we
presented earlier so in this case all
this relate party the ID provider Alice
if they want to use an if they want to
use a system essentially if you want to
get the formal guarantees that we talked
about they have to run their own site
tree node because if the contacting some
site tree node as a service like such a
service could be lying right you won't
get any other guarantees but in fact we
can get most of those guarantees by by
using some of the ideas that we
presented earlier I won't go into a lot
of those details but in principle what
we can do is we can have this verifiable
hashes that are sitting between this
relying party and this D ID or Alice and
this D ID system and and and such a
system can provide the information but
also generate a log using which you can
verify that such a system is not lying
but we can talk offline if you're
interested in those things so that's the
high-level view of what I wanted to talk
about so but so at this point so let me
conclude so we we saw that blockchains
is a very interesting technology because
it can give provide proofs of
transactions and but it it comes with
like limitations in abstractions and
performance and in particular it we end
up a lot of reinventing the wheel and
and what we do in very were the division
of Veritas project is used to cut is to
basically combine the advantages of
blockchain but also retrofit
verifiability to existing platforms and
overlay them on top of a blockchain so
that existing applications can so
existing applications can use existing
systems and we kind of Illustrated many
of these ideas in the context of the
sigh tree and CID project any questions
for right so I didn't talk about
recovery and in fact that question is
one of the reasons why we need to use
blockchain right because blockchain
makes it very easy for Alice to go and
say hey I lost the key at this point and
every transaction up to up to a certain
point is valid and everything else was
happened in terms by an adversary and
and so he here's a new key for that I
will be using so essentially what I
didn't speak about is like we have some
inbuilt protocol partner protocol where
when you when you consider a new ID ID I
can have a regular private key and a
public key and I keep the private key
and I also have a special key called the
recovery key and I can use it use the
recovery key to show that something went
wrong and I want to basically ignore
some transaction right I spoke very
briefly about it I didn't get to the
details but we can use we can basically
achieve the same properties where I
Alice can verify some property with with
Bob but without revealing anything about
her other than other than the fact that
that property exists so she can prove to
Bob that her license mentions that our
age is more than 21 without revealing
any other details about when she was
born or residence and any other things
but it's like most of it my
understanding is I'm not an expert in
zero knowledge proves my understanding
is that such protocols exist like at
this point we have not built any of
those things but we are aware of those
possibilities
yes he is directly right that is right
so yeah so like like maybe Mansur was
more complicated than it need to be I
was talking in the context of
information that is present in the
license itself but yes but any her
university degree you is probably it's
just a hash in her document so bob is
not gonna learn about it but bob would
learn about a public key certainly yeah
so what degree the system can scale in
terms of rates and Oh verifiable caches
I didn't write and get to talk much we
have a paper which is a basis for some
of these things it's it appeared in last
year's sigmoid it's called concerto so
let's take a look at it for verifiable
caches and for the scalability or the
basic system itself we at this point
it's BST prototyping but it's all open
source you can go and check out the code
and play around with it or you can run
your existing site tree no it's all
there so so we are not properly you know
we are not looking at the performance
you have no we do not have benchmark
numbers and things like that but we have
designed the system with performance in
mind so the way we do that is when we
get a large number of transactions we
like buy transactions I mean operations
like nudie ID or update
we just put all of them we consider
Merkle tree and we just ember the root
of the Merkle tree in the blockchain so
what is one one transaction the
blockchain could be hundred thousand
transactions I was talking about so
Reach is basically four reads you are
basically running your own site tree
node right so once you consume the
information the blockchain you are just
using a regular data structure and in
the the original proposal like you own
your node so you can keep everything in
main memory we can serve rates you can
use the latest and best technology for
it still right but once you read from
the block anything it's much simpler
yeah the read is just out of a cache and
you can have as many caches as you want
right yeah so you don't have to log
reads you don't have to put reads but
that's a special pattern here where you
don't have to log it because there's no
concurrence oh yeah yeah it sides it's
it's beyond a prototype so it's like
it's all open source we are kind of
building the system on you own the
retrofitting the open idea is still
conceptual but the sightly platform
itself is open source and you can check
out the code you know run your own site
you node you probably need some bitcoins
for that but yeah it is expensive but
yet now if there has already been a big
announcement with MasterCard and
essentially active Isaac the azure
active directory owns this now this is a
real this is Rehan great thanks again
[Applause]
you